does it feel more real now that you're
doing interviews about this like does it
make you more excited or more nervous
that this is coming out now
i'm a little more excited because you
know it's it's
my favorite part of this industry is set
life and being on set with cast and crew
and um building bonds and kind of
finding
that's how i kind of find my family is
set to set you know
um and i always i just i fall in love
with our
our cast and crew but i get a little
nervous when i realize that it's no
longer just
ours our little isolated pod and story
it's going to be like out there for
public consumption
but everyone today has been
really nice and reassuring so i feel
good
yeah and that's the thing i mean selena
i don't use the word lightly i mean
celine is a legend
like what did it feel like taking that
on was it was the immense pressure to do
so much pressure but i was it was such
an honor
and so emotional and so beautiful and i
was just so
grateful and excited and terrified and
all of the emotions
but i think having that pressure and
having that fear
really was essential because it created
this drive to do things correctly and to
really study and to stay up nights to
make sure that this was done
with such respect and care and
you know all i want is for the fans to
enjoy this experience watching the show
to see
her hard work and dedication and to have
fun
and you know i'm so proud of our cast
and crew for putting as much in as they
did everyone
has so much love for the fan base and
selena and her family and
i i think it really shows yeah and
that's the thing in terms of fans like
you're going to hear from selena fans
and i'm wondering like coming from
twilight coming from walking dead that
have such big fandoms
do you feel like you're more prepared to
deal with the selena
fandom yeah i am really lucky in that
i've done a lot of projects that have
really incredible
fan bases and pretty intense fan bases
but
so i think i am prepared you know i felt
i knew what this was going to be i knew
what i was walking into and so
i i feel really really well prepared and
you know i'm so proud of what we've done
and there's been such a great
response and you know selena fans i am a
selena fan those are my homies and so
i just i want everyone to know that i
really thought
of selena and thought of them and and we
did everything that we could
yeah i find it fascinating too that not
only are you playing selena
but there's another element that this
was jennifer lopez's
breakout role to playing salinas so i
was like is there an extra layer of
pressure that not only playing selena
but i'm playing this role that jennifer
lopez
made so famous for herself yeah because
she did such a great job and i loved
that movie and grew up watching that
movie over and over and over again and i
know that movie backwards and forwards
um and you know i respect jennifer so
much
too for being the pioneer that she was
as well for our community in latinas so
um yeah i have nothing but respect and
i'm just so glad that people are gonna
get to see our take as well yeah and
that's the thing like how do you think
this series is different like what does
it bring
new to the story of selena we're
a show so we get so much more time and
our first season
is is so much incredible backstory to
the legend that we know you know
um and as a selena fan myself i was
i was learning i was learning so much
more about her i was i had
i saw so many photos and so many videos
of
her early years of uh like 1415
and was shocked that that was selena
because
i was ignorant i thought that selena
looked the way that she looked
for throughout her career and that's
that's not true and that's what i love
about our first season is that
you're getting to see her coming of age
and finding who she wanted to be as an
artist and and evolving into the
icon then the legend that we know you
know she was
not always very influenced by flamenco
and
you know like she that was acquired and
so i'm excited that people are going to
see the phase of her life where she
was a lot more influenced by
80s and michael jackson and paula abdul
i think that's going to be really
fascinating for fans
you